I think it's absolutely insane that
Kamala is actually going to be in one of
the biggest Marvel games that we've done
she's a very recent addition to the
Marvel Universe she was only invented
gosh about six years ago but even though
she was very new she's very classic she
is a young hero from jersey city and she
has something called polymorph powers
which means she can contort her body in
different ways and she can get really
big and really small we spent countless
hours on the story on the choice of
character how we would portray her I
loved working with Shana Skye and the
rest of the creative team at Crystal
Dynamics to sit down with Shaun and talk
about the characters and how he saw them
to stay true to her we spent a lot of
time in the comics and then also tapping
into our version of her the biggest
difference between our game and the
koala people of may have met in the
comics she gains her powers on a day she
is essentially just a little fangirl
right she's a nerd
she loves the Marvel Universe she lives
in the Marvel Universe her fan fiction
comic is selected for the Avengers
celebrations the Avengers are unveiling
this experimental technology and
something pretty crazy happens with it
she's exposed to torsion gas and is now
labeled to what is called an inhuman
she's got superpowers that she doesn't
know what to do with in a world that
hates superheroes she suspects that the
Avengers were set up in a day the role
that Kamala plays is a unifier she's
really someone who is going to bring the
Avengers back together
casting Kamala was a difficult process
we spent a lot of time looking for
Sandra and she did an impeccable job
bringing her life oh my gosh when I
found out I was gonna play the role of
Kamala Khan I was like are you kidding
I'm an Avenger she's a lot like the
character in many ways so there's
instant relatability
she is first-generation American like me
she's a young woman of color who has
trouble fitting in like I do and I feel
like she has all these personal
struggles that everyone can relate to in
the cast of season actors she is the new
one in some sense that that forced
structure between the seasoned actors
and the new actor is sort of like the
actual Kamala Khan relationship to her
world and to her environment we wanted
to really focus on her gameplay and her
style of moves reflecting her
development as a character so you might
notice that there's at least one or two
attacks that she sort of like made her
own from the other Avengers and sort of
integrated into her moveset one of the
most iconic things about Kamala is her
ability to envision and we actually
realized this in a bunch of different
ways she's able to like lengthen her
attacks she's able to avoid attacks
while she's sort of minion Biggins and
then we also have the ultra and bigan
state where she gets giant sized and at
this point she's able to send enemies
flying we actually built an entirely new
reaction set for the enemies to like
really deliver on the feel of being you
know three times four times the size of
the the enemies are sort of kicking
around putting together movement so for
Kamala is just all in the imagination I
feel because at the end of the day it's
you who's standing there in this mocap
space imagining that your arm
Sandra's arm is stretching out to the
end of the room to grab somebody it's
just fun
I hope the fans noticed those little
details and I hope the fans see how hard
every single person worked and I hope
the fans love the story as much as I do
when it comes to a new perspective on
the Avengers seeing them from a fangirl
of someone who has always wanted to meet
them just wanted to be one we feel like
players can really connect with that
Marvel has considered her an important
enough character to be on the League of
the Avengers she's got superhero powers
unlike any other Avenger she's not
laying down for no one and I think those
qualities they crossed boundaries people
can relate to it she's rebellious they
want to be her I want to be her the fact
that she's the entry point character in
this game makes so much sense because
she really is the everyman like people
from all backgrounds and experiences can
relate to her and have related to her
since her inception so it makes perfect
sense for her to be bringing you into
the Marvel Avengers game experience
you
[Music]